thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with the youngest competitor in the
event alice lee only 12 years of age but
so much experience already alice first
of all congratulations
that first game was back and forth it
felt like you had the advantage then
your opponent had a winning advantage
and after that everything was settled in
the time travel situation how did you
feel about that game um well i was
basically just trying to play my moves
yeah i mean i felt that it was kind of
back and forth because um i feel like my
opening was kind of good but
after that i let her kind of
let her work invade to like c3 and that
was kind of annoying
and after that i was able to like trade
some pieces i think we probably both
made some mistakes um but in the
obstacle bishop end game uh yeah i think
um she was she just had a bit lower time
and that was basically how i won
and in the second game you were playing
with black pieces a draw would have been
enough for you but you sacrificed an
exchange out of the opening did you
speak with your coach before that was
that the preparation how did you
approach that game oh um
i mean uh for some reason like i think i
was planning to play uh the like
uh what i played against her previously
which was like um e6 and then d64 um
that would transpose into the qga but
like i figured that it was um okay to
like kind of avoid her prep
and because i yeah she probably prepared
against that also and uh so i played
something different and i don't think
she was expecting it and the exchange
stack line um can be very tactical but
the line she played i got kind of a
solid position um i'm not sure how much
i was worth by or better by
you won against one of the most talented
players in the nation you're moving on
to the next round you're going to be
facing tatev abrahamian how does uh how
do you feel right now um well i'm still
a bit in shock because the first game
was kind of crazy and the second game
was um also
not completely clear
but of course it's great to be finally
able to um vote after like two days and
four games to be able to advance
um i think
it was based on like a bit of luck but
i'm also like management with like time
strategy that sort of stuff
so yeah i think yeah it's great to be
able to win the match
alice so much entertainment you gave us
and the fans as well congratulations and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you our
congratulations to alice very well done
young lady